шановні українці А як ви знаєте для того
щоби Україна цього року змогла розпочати
офіційні перемовини щодо вступу України
до ЄС а Маємо виконати сім
обов'язкових передумов і боротьба з
корупцією реально боротьба з корупцією а
не оці ритуальні танці які намагаються
ввести Влада одна з цих складових тому
прийняття закону Про відновлення
декларування це ну от ключовий пункт
Що стосується боротьби з корупцією Наша
команда якраз
вела це законодавство ми створили
антикорупційну інфраструктуру і хочемо
сказати що
прозоро всі подавали декларації Як ви
знаєте тільки прийшла Ця команда до
влади тут конституційний суд скасовував
взагалі
декларування тепер уже от більше ніж
півтора роки немає декларування і зараз
іде дискусія щодо закону до другого
читання Наша команда Ми не з паном тут
займалися депутатським а подали
конкретні пропозиції на яких ми будемо
наполягати перше це прозорість
декларації всі декларації мають бути в
публічному просторі і це принципове
питання Друге звичайно маємо захистити
наших військових які сьогодні на фронті
які не має можливості бігати збирати
папірці а заповнення декларації Повірте
це достатньо така копітка робота
очевидно що військові Заповніть
декларації після закінчення війни І тому
ми стоїмо на тому що військові на фронті
мають отримати такі відтермінування щодо
заповнення декларації але всі
військкомати всі посади які причетні до
будь-яких корупційних ризиків в системі
Міністерства оборони всі міністри
заступники міністрів оборони і оці всі
ділове забезпечення обов'язково мають
декларуватися це наша чітка позиція Ну і
третя і ключове по чому сьогодні є
грандіозні скандали і небажання почути
нашу позицію яка є принциповою
ігноруватися всі представники офісу
президента штатні і позаштатні адже саме
офіс президента сьогодні фактично керує
країнами банкове підмінила собою
Міністерство закордонних справ Банкова
вирішує всі контракти щодо Міністерства
оборони Банкова керує урядом Банкова
сьогодні керує парламентом окрім
європейської солідарності і коли ми
бачимо міжнародні перемовини на яких
Україну представляють не дипломати не
офіційні
представники української влади а
позаштатні радники офісу президента вони
сьогодні керують країною коли ці
позаштатні радники і радниці телефонують
в регіони і дають вказівки навіть там
податковим структурам коли вони ведуть
телеграм-канали банкової брудні
абсолютно за корупційні кошти коли вони
їздять на незрозумілі абсолютно
позиціях з незрозумілими директивами
представляти Україну в міжнародних
перемовинах звичайно люди які мають
безпосередній вплив на прийняття рішень
і державної влади мають декларуватися
так само як всі керівники і представники
державних підприємств от останній
приклад і мій колега Артур дасть Тут
більш таку розгорнуту позицію по
нашим принципам щодо декларування А я
хочу сказати про державні підприємства в
тому числі наприклад мультимедійну про
платформу яка сьогодні по суті є
частиною марафону Хоча не транслюється в
Марафоні але закупає за гроші
держбюджету програми вірнією сплачує їх
олігархічним каналом плюсам Інтер і таке
інше І коли 2 млрд державних гривень іде
на Марафон на Фріда на дом нараду
Скажіть будь ласка А чому ці люди не
мають декларуватися обов'язково мають
декларуватися так само як всі інші
державні підприємства де зарплати
зашкалюють щомісячні сотні тисяч гривень
набагато більше більше ніж зарплата
президента міністрів ви депутатів і тому
люди які живуть за бюджет за кошти
бюджету іноді не демонструючи при цьому
якоюсь ефективності тому що більшість
цих державних підприємств є збитковими
вони мають декларуватись І знаєте От
коли сьогодні йдуть оці чутки там щодо
того що може бути зміна міністра оборони
і таке інше хочу одне сказати що питання
не в прізвищах питання в системі тому
наша команда буде вимагати прозорості
під звітності повернення години запитань
до уряду звіту всіх міністрів і тих хто
йдуть і тих хто приходять для того щоб
розуміти що відбувається з державним
бюджетом
європейська Солідарність тримала тримає
І буде тримати єдність навколо збройних
сил України навколо наших бійців які
сьогодні на фронті бородять незалежність
Української держави
елот знаєте
чітко спадає на думку що хто не тримає
цю єдність навколо збройних сил України
це українська влада тому що скрізь Ми
чуємо що грошей на військо не вистачає
але ви знаєте
ці гроші в державі є і ми чітко
розуміємо що якщо почнеться реальна
боротьба з корупцією а не боротьба з
корупцією на папері якщо прозоро
повернуть майже скрізь окрім секретних
закупівель а не будуть його вбивати
кожною другою дією то тоді і гроші
з'являться і такі історії як велика
краківництво на асфальті Яке зараз ви
подивіться просто мільярди витрачаються
такі історії як яйця по 17 гривень такі
історії як 36 зниклих мільярдів гривень
міністерстві оборони Вони не будуть
можливі а ці гроші можна буде спрямувати
на підтримку наших солдат
і один з елементів
всієї цієї концепції це якраз є
повернення декларування але як сказав
вже сказала Ірина категорично Влада не
хоче повертати декларування
співробітників офісу президента України
так званих позаштатних радників які
сьогодні
виступають в ЗМІ дають вказівки
виступають від імені держави присутні в
міжнародних делегаціях вони присутні на
секретних зустрічах і впливають на
прийняття рішень А скажіть будь ласка А
за що вони живуть
вони за повітря живуть а Ми впевнені що
хтось за якісь їхні думки їм щось не
доплачує от саме для того жорстка
позиція європейського солідарності щоб
будь-який співробітник влади Сьогодні
має декларуватися а що стосується
державних підприємств знаєте я от тримаю
в руках останні заголовки тільки за
декілька останніх днів
як чиновники держпідприємств роками
обкрадають державу
теж підприємством він молодь спорту
витратити 300 мільйонів на ремонт
тенісних корків це зараз під час війни
Це більше ніж міністр Федоров збирав на
дрони Камікадзе А ось це дуже цікаво
стаття вищого антикорупційного суду
наскільки він ефективний це написали
якраз судді вищого антикорупційного суду
цитую дослівно
топ-менеджмент державних підприємств -
це одна з найбільших категорій учасників
справ про корупційні злочини і з
урахуванням цього
ми маємо розуміти дуже просту річ
чи мають вони отримати велике зарплати
сьогодні чи ні Ну скажімо Так це
суперечливе питання Я особисто вважаю що
під час війни ні Але тим не менше дуже
часто
виникає питання Чому підприємство
збиткове а керівники отримують 100 тисяч
200 тисяч і 300 тисяч та інколи
мільйонні зарплати і ми вважаємо що
суспільство громадян України мають чітко
знати хто з цих директорів відпрацьовує
і підприємство приносить прибуток А хто
з цих директорів призначаю собі зарплати
і премії зі збитків і це є важливим саме
тому європейська Солідарність подала
свої пропозиції до законопроекту про
повернення декларування якими ми чітко
фіксуємо що військові не мають сьогодні
витрачати час на декларування за
виключенням
військкоматів
військово-лікарських комісій і тих хто
відповідає за закупівлю
сьогодні всі представники влади мають
декларуватися особливо представники
офісу президента Які сьогодні контролює
все в цій державі і також мають
декларуватися керівники державних
підприємств для того щоб суспільство
побачила Чи це збиткові підприємства і
керівники отримують велике зарплату чи
вони дають прибутки
дякуємо за увагу Ну і хочу знаєте додати
колеги Що звичайно повернення
декларування - це важливий елемент
боротьби з корупцією але недостатній
наприклад сьогодні
журналісти-розслідувачі чи не щотижня
даються дуже шокуючі матеріали Правда в
Інтернеті тому що їх не показують
Марафоні навіть суспільне мовлення
наприклад не знайшло час показати
розслідування бігуса щодо отриманих
родиною заступника керівника офісу
президента 320 мільйонів гривень за так
звану зелену енергію продану окупованим
територіям ну тобто по суті Росії але
Зверніть увагу що жодного розслідування
не почалося
немає позиції тут Ані президента які там
щодня з відео виходить і реагував навіть
на відпустки депутатів а тут ідеться про
його офіс про його підлеглих і ані слова
ані пари з вуст друге немає позиції тут
і антикорупційних органів вони не почали
кримінальне провадження вони не почали
розслідування щодо цього як і по
великому будівництву і таке інше і тому
наше бачення людей які створювали
антикорупційну інфраструктуру голосують
що за ці закони е-е
деячі зелене світло і створенню і назк і
Набу І сап що все-таки боротьба з топ
корупцією це в першу чергу дуже ретельно
аналіз і
повага до бюджетних коштів от як вони
витрачаються А щоб в нас знаєте все не
перетворилося просто на процес і на дуже
часто боротьбу з неугодними замість того
щоб дійсно розслідувати корупцію вони
дуже дивно що от сюжет про
шурму цими розслідуваннями не вийшов
навіть на суспільному мовленні хочу
нагадати що в наш час коли ми були
владою саме суспільне мовлення давали
своєму ефірі всі розслідування бігуса
всі розслідування
ткачановного і інше правда А зараз дуже
класна повне мовчання під егідою знаєте
воєнного стану в нас політична цензура і
очевидно що наша команда окрім всього
перераховано тих позицій які є нашими
поправками до Закону Про відновлення
декларування будучи вимагати щоб ці
дебати в парламенті були публічними щоб
там була преса щоб експерти могли чути
позиції і бачити хто що відстоює Хто як
голосує а не все тишкам-нишком і галочку
поставити у рами виконали зобов'язання
перед європейською стороною такого не
буде європейська Солідарність робить це
для того щоб Україна не фасадно
демонструвала демократію а дійсно була
країною яка рухається до є сенату дякую